what we basically did was we installed
something called a back door on your
system that then would connect out to a
computer we controlled allowing us to
execute commands on your computer so at
that point we could share your screen
see exactly what you were looking at at
all times we could record off the webcam
to watch you as you walked around the
room hijack your Skype sessions so how
did you get my credit card information
every time you press a button there's an
event that happens in the machine and we
can capture that you can see here we
have your credit card information from
when you were booking your trip to Cuba
is there any personal information of
mine that you couldn't have gotten
access to
I don't think so so you could have
hijacked my whole identity yeah and you
know the attacks we pulled off here
really weren't hyper sophisticated so I
always like to say if someone wants to
hack you they're going to be able to